hey guys it's Courtney tez Ono and
welcome to another et live we are really
excited today because we have a special
guest who you all love on power as
Angela miss Lila Lauren thank you for
joining us thank you for having me
of course so everyone is really excited
if you've seen last night's episode then
you have a lot of questions so be sure
to send those our way and I'll make sure
we get little to answer those and if you
have not watched power yet you might not
want to sway together now boiler alert
come on back and hopefully we answer
those questions for you so let's go
ahead and dive right in because we have
a lot of ground to cover so the episode
actually ends with ghost who is now
questioning whether he needs to he wants
to be a better man but he shows up to
your doorstep so I mean that instantly
made me think that our ghost and Angela
are gonna be back on soon I mean we you
don't know yet he's he's a thing with
happy birthday is like goes to sort of
been brought all the way down to rock
bottom and you know he's lost his
daughter he's lost respect to his son
Tasha's in love with somebody else you
know at this point and so Angela like
yes he loves Angela but also we have to
think of like they fell in love as kids
because there's that crazy history there
and so he's just he knocks on her door
cuz it's almost like he's you know
Australia doesn't know where else to go
right I thought that and then I was
thinking could it be closure for him
because when you want to become a better
person you kind of check things off your
list and some yeah I think he's ready to
get some stuff off his chest okay
because she's asked him to be honest
oh and he's like hasn't done it he's
liked her over and over and over again
and so there's a little piece of he's
just like I want to be a better man like
right so we're gonna have some tough
conversations and we with Angela and
ghost I mean we're starting off with
some really big big questions but one of
the biggest things tweeted about last
night was Kendrick Lamar know he was so
good I mean out of a rapper that has had
an acting debut I think his was one of
the best one you really can he had like
prepared and he'd comedy come to play
and like God I mean sure he's had
experience performing but stepping into
another character and being loosed like
that like I don't think I could have
pulled that off if I'd I stopped for a
really long time a little I'm a little
off you know you're in awe of his music
his his his use of words and his
political commentary and his rap and so
then for him to come in and kill it
you're like okay he did do a great job
and he talked to Courtney ahead of time
on why this role was one that he wants
to take on it's really nice that he
didn't have the typical you know thug
role and that we saw him as a drug a
drug addict but really like when you
okay it's there's this in like old
literature and in like Shakespeare time
there's the role of the fool like Parker
there's these characters that are
outside the margins and they get to tell
the truth and they get to sort of put
things in a different perspective and
that's he's kind of like a seer he's
sort of like sure he's a drug dealer but
he has this sort of crackpot wisdom that
comes out and it's a really fun
departure for power it was a really
great debut so we actually have him
talking about it with Courtney and let's
see why he took on this role be
something that um people predict or know
I want to be something out of the
ordinary but some I connect to at the
same time and yeah
drug abuser Lacey's a hothead I do that
she's ready to go always on the take and
it's just a character that I know I know
so well she's growing up in Compton you
know you have relatives or you have
dudes that around the corner that you
actually grow up with
there's been a neighborhood before you I
mean he was literally perfect for this
role because I mean he has that
background growing up in Compton and it
showed on screen when he doesn't love I
feel like now fans are wondering is he
going to be a recurring character cuz he
did so great oh my god we would love
that
I kind of think he's got you know yeah
he's a busy man
exactly well that was one of the
highlights of last night's episode
another thing that we saw or that we've
been seeing this season you touched on
it in the very beginning talking about
the unlikely parent and yes we've got a
chance to see you and Tasha yes and then
we saw a glimpse of me showing up a
Tommy exactly so what is in store as far
as the journey with you and Tommy are
you taken to resi down together I think
like I don't know if cuz Angela doesn't
know teresi so this is like a thing
where you as the audience member have
information than Angela Angela's trying
to take down the Jimenez then I thought
she got robbed of you know and so she's
thinking she can use Tommy to do that
because she thinks he's she gets it
wrong and thinks that he's their distro
exactly so she's pairing up with him you
know sort of like what was that term the
enemy of my enemy is my friend yes so
Tommy you know so and that's really fun
yeah I love working with Joseph Shakur
oh yeah what so spent that bin like cuz
I know his character so different from
who he is as Tommy on care oh yeah but
when he's on set man it's like Tommy
it's just it's a lot of fun because we I
also you get to play and this thing
where you see they're kind of high
school versions of the way like Angela's
not calm and collected around him as he
scares her and he keeps showing up I
mean she had that gun in her back pocket
yeah yeah except you know what's really
funny about that so you know nowadays we
use women we're always wearing those
stretchy jeans and those can't support
the weight of a real gun so every time
they would have me put a real gun back
there it would like fall down like fall
down my pants in my pants and so you
have this like diaper but gun situation
happening and so we're like what do we
do we need some
and in Angela's apartment there's a bowl
of plastic fruit I literally had a
plastic banana back there the gun like
that is it's a fake stack government
it's really heavy and it just wasn't
working so you know who would've thought
a banana without the data I think
there's a blooper reel well I like
literally take it out and point the
banana it oh that's so cute I love
hearing that
Tommie obviously is a little he's a
little amateur and when it comes to this
new father-son dynamic because he hasn't
had a dad and oh yeah so iced tea for us
he is so thirsty yeah and who can blame
a kid you don't grow up with the parents
and you find it exist it opens up a hole
in you exactly but I feel like by
episode five we're fine finally seeing
that he may be on tutor se in some ways
are you gonna help him at all like
unknowingly help him figure out the
motive of teresi that I can't like teas
but like that's sort of that thing that
I don't know Angela never does she does
very few things unless it kind of also
helps her there's also the one time that
she did something nice that landed her
in hot water like like help me telling
Tasha where tarik was like that was a
one generous kind moment human moment
and like Lua it just yeah goes
unpunished so the question is whether
she doesn't know who he is like Saks and
and MOC know who he is and so the
question is like she doesn't know who
this informant is at all so she has to
figure that out too
okay so it's gonna be a journey yeah so
yeah are there going to be any more odd
pairings because I know we have you and
Tommy now but it seems like we may have
something else on the horizon can we see
that
I think that's gonna continue okay you
know I think it's gonna continue
throughout the season we have a question
from Miss in I hope it's India India
Davis from YouTube says did you want to
play this role or did you have the
option to be Jamie's wife no as an actor
you
just they like they have like Angela
from jump was Puerto Rican and so that's
sort of what they were going and Tasha
they wanted like a very specific
archetype and and then like did I want I
wanted to get a job because I was
unemployed I wanted to not have to move
in with my parents that's a really good
one
now one thing I noticed is that every
episode it seems like Tommy is closer to
death how crazy would it be if power did
that this season are they going to do
that to power fans with the major
character I mean once you kill a kid on
the show and like I think the genre of
television has been so up ended by like
some of these great cable shows like
Game of Thrones like red wedding when
they just killed everybody that like ya
know character is safe so I mean it
would be devastating but like I would
Creole like in some level this year
everybody's got potential crosshairs on
them everyone's gonna get the axe at
some point yeah right yeah but I would
love for Dre to get the axe a little
sooner
character like they want a character to
die like yeah okay well um Tommy I think
that like I said I think that he may be
on tutor se but are we going to see him
kind of tap into a little bit more of an
emotional side since this is his dad
yeah I think I mean I think that's an
inevitability you know and and that it's
gonna be really interesting to see how
how ghost navigates it too cuz ghost has
never really had had to have competition
for Tommy's heart right you know when
you really think of the show like the
relationship that he has with Angela and
that love for Angela is mirrored in his
relationship with Tommy and that
brotherly love with Tommy romance yeah
oh man
well I hope that he gets on to him
sooner than later I think you've got a
crush on Tommy I think he is one of my
favorite outside of you I do love you
this season maybe yeah
we've developed a love relationship now
I was talking madre it's he in over his
head trying to go after ghosts because
he really is like he was once his
understudy he was taught by ghosts and
now it seems like they are going head to
head in a lot of ways I you know Dre is
definitely shooting for the moon and the
wonderful thing about power is like one
episode he'll have the upper hand and he
thinks he's getting traction in the next
episode he's like way down at the bottom
again and I don't I think as long as
ghosts and Kanan are alive Dre is going
to be kind of caught in the middle of
like what his agenda is like he's
because he's the one who's he's the
underdog yeah so yeah he is a hundred
percent over his head but you know
people still sometimes make those crazy
you know three-pointers are across the
cord shots and it works out so that's
he's definitely the wild card right
there have been some crazy fan theories
and I obviously want to know what is the
craziest that you've heard but one is
that Rashad Tate I want to make sure I
get this right this fan theory Rashaad
take can't be trusted it seems like he's
trying to take down ghosts could he and
Terry be working together oh well okay
so there no because the problem with
Terry is Terry is is a white hat he is
sort of truly incorruptible and so
basically I could see like Simon Stern
and congressman Rashad working together
but like in terms of what the characters
stand for
you'd have to Terry's character would
have to arc so completely like you can
see him lying for Tasha maybe for love
but there's limits to where to isn't
what he's gonna sacrifice in terms of
his integrity right I think a lot of
people that had those fan theories are
probably thinking like you know angela
has done this for ghost so maybe Tasha's
love interest would do the same you know
to take down ghosts in a way for his
love for Tasha but you're right but
working wild like congressman should
like that's a good that's
another level right what's been the
wildest theory that you've heard so far
oh I think the Kanan being Tasha's baby
daddy well it's also just a logical cuz
like he wasn't I mean it was just yeah
no he's not
Tasha's baby daddy it is funny though
when people have these like really crazy
theories like wow that's like really
complicated like the simpler the simpler
the better
yeah well speaking of Tasha and Kanan
are we ever gonna find out they're back
history because it does seem like
there's some type type of tension there
that could have been a romantic past
will they ever explain why Tasha so
upset I think it gets touched on we're
like Canaan's got a Ledge for her and
that's like when somebody that imposing
like dresses like you know dresses you
down with your eyes like that's a scary
thing as a woman there's no part of you
that like and she knows what he's
capable if he killed his own son and she
also knows what she's guilty of she
knows that her and ghosts set him up to
go to prison so I think they don't like
a combination of guilt and just like
Kanan is just the worst human one
awesome knowing that he has legitimate
beef and not trusting this truce because
if someone did that to Tasha like and
sent her to prison for 10 years I don't
think it's it's a hard thing to write
like she's smart to be like I feel like
he's playing you guys and he's going to
turn on you right now do you think I
know a lot of people were so upset with
tarik including myself in the beginning
of the season oh yeah you know I mean
this entire thing has kind of been on
him with Rana but is he a little smarter
than we think when it comes to his
relationship with Kanan no kid he's a
kid that's that's sort of where it's
like we're we're it's when you're 16 17
years old you have this all this bravado
that you think you like figured
everything out but the truth is you
haven't you don't so you know well it'll
be interesting to see how that plays out
but no he's a teenager right and I'm so
happy sorry I'm so happy that Tommy
actually spoke up finally it was about
time that he had that conversation with
to read
because he needs to stop you know the
question is whether tariqas sail-like
salvageable save along this point if
he's gone past the tipping point I have
a little hope for him on that part but
yeah we'll see Jane from YouTube says
who is the biggest prankster on set and
do you guys have a text chain oh no we
don't have a text oh I like to do pranks
really I mean in terms of my world maybe
I mean I don't we operate in really
separate worlds I think probably the
most extra thing I've done was I left a
deer head and Joseph shakarez dressing
room with no comment like no no sitting
on the couch this random deer head yeah
I could even get the deer head from a
friend was moving and she was like hey
do you want it I was like this would be
perfect that would be the last thing
that I would think will be on our set
and then whenever a character dies I may
or may not have like a funeral pyre of
flowers with the rest in peace like in
like in their trailer a full shrine yeah
with like a eat your feelings snack box
like oh you're a real prankster what did
you do for Reina when they kill rain off
well actually I because she was a guy
I've done it for like David Fumero for
Andy bean for loose you know
yeah that was like you know I just got
killed off here's some popcorn and
chocolate but it's also cuz it's not you
know you shoot the scene you're all
covered in blood and you have to go back
to your dressing room to undress and
it's nice to kind of poke fun and create
a ritual of it and right now
who doesn't want it's really funny
though calling the florist because they
think there's like rest in peace like
Mike Sandoval's character played by
David Romero we his nickname is Miguel
sandy balls I
your sense of humor though in most words
don't even expect that from from your
character it is a character my friends I
have very different oh my gosh Matthew
from YouTube says hi which season of
Power has been your favorite you know
what the first cuz it was new we were
like green little newbies New York was
new none of us were used to this it was
just there's nothing sort of like
there's nothing like your first time I
was like it was just it was that first
season was really lovely oh my gosh I
would agree but season 5 is pretty
amazing because we just have so many
layers yeah
it's everything yeah evolved exactly
yeah
now one thing I'm noticing from the last
episode and a few few episodes
especially rayna's funeral is that
Tasha's mom may know best when it comes
to her relationship with Terry now is
she turning a blind eye because she's in
love or could her mom be on to something
I think Tasha's mom is a lot like pause
where when you stand on the outside of
something it becomes very clear and very
evident like boo what are you doing um
but that's the thing when it comes like
Tasha is an adult she's a mom and her
own right she's an individual and what
does her mom really gonna do mm-hmm
besides give her like the side-eye or
you know that's trailer what's up or I
think she slapped her in one episode
yeah you know so but that's sort of the
extent of it she can't well it seems
like her mom is so traditional so I was
thinking maybe she just values you know
marriage is very sacred so maybe that
could be it but then I'm thinking in
terms of in on the the criminality of
the couple and like she knows the risks
like you know when you have a marriage
that's also based on drug dealing like
that's a really dangerous thing to leave
especially when you're dating a lawyer
mm-hmm and not everybody is like Angela
in the scenario where she would actually
fight on the other side well but also
like Angela put ghosts in jail because
she thought you murdered somebody so
like Terry's in that same way the reason
why Angela's working with them is
because she accidentally got herself
implicated so it's her own survival
system yeah kicking in if she was still
on the other side of the law
I mean I don't know if she would be
helping in the way that she's helping
okay so so Angela still has some selfish
motives in there still
yeah well it's yeah it's cuz it's her
fate is it like if she goes down
everybody else goes down and if someone
else goes down they all go down it's
like lap sitting for jail necks right
you know it's like blaming her cuz it's
a selfish motive it's like well yeah but
I mean everybody at this point is trying
to save their own hides right yeah I
want to play a quick quick rapid-fire
round called power play with you before
we get into our exclusive clip that we
have for you guys for the next episode
so stay tuned so who do you think is the
biggest threat this season Tommy Tariq
Canaan or teresi ooh
I think teresi okay I mean I could see
that which character arcs will surprise
us the most the season if you could
choose one Tasha Tasha I hope you're not
don't lie to me don't lie to me okay are
we in for any major deaths by the end of
the season like from always its power
okay
tarik has been the most hated character
oh we talked about this if he's smarter
running the Canaan you said he's a kid
okay so we're gonna go ahead and show
you guys an exclusive clip of episode
six so go ahead and take a look you know
Andy you just keep showing up
for me not my family what everything has
happened why is there I don't know
did you just come over here last night
because the tyre kicked you out no I
came over because I owed you an apology
told you the truth that's the truth
about when you said it was the right
decision to end things between us
that night almost killed me
me too
how do I trust you
who's a lot of emotions in this oh
goodness the last thing that you say in
in this clip is that can you trust
ghosts can you trust him with your heart
anymore I think that's what Angela's
asking cuz it's also in that clip he he
tells her why he broke up with her he
tells are the truth of it and and and so
it's that it's sort of like well it's he
is this honesty gonna continue can't you
know so she's still in the question of
it question I have it seems like that's
the morning after so in the morning I
think it's that night okay so we pick up
right where we left off okay so we don't
know yet if Angela can trust ghosts with
their heart but what kind of
conversation are we going to have going
I know we had an intense one there but
could we see a friendship or is this
going to be completely cut off I think
like right now there it's like okay
you're being honest let me be honest and
who are we now mm-hmm you know Raina's
death really leveled the playing field
yeah you know I don't know if it's ever
happened to you where you're mad at
someone and then some life thing happens
and all of a sudden they just that stuff
doesn't really matter as much anymore
the piece though is you know Angela he
doesn't know that she's working with
Tasha oh okay obviously yeah we're still
watching his power power audience yeah
and so like and she's been leaving him
out of stuff because he's been clearly a
little like in crazy town like yeah and
so it's also interesting with Angela
what she's asking him like can I trust
you
she's also like he's afraid at the edges
like he's not really in a reliable
stable place either now I want to talk
about the fact that you guys have had
such a journey with each other
and it almost seems like angela is a
drug for ghosts will we see him break
old habits or is this something that
will expose that they really Archer
loves I think that's really interesting
because they're different true loves
from the beginning if Angela's a drug
for ghost she's equally a drug for her
they imprinted on each other at such a
young age and that sort of been the core
of power is like they have a love for
each other and like big capital letters
and they have a love that exists outside
the bounds of morality and like what do
you do with that right like Courtney
sets up this wonderful conflict of you
know here's this huge epic love and he's
married with kids and what do you how do
you navigate right and things are a
little different now though because his
marriage is alone yeah that's why she
doesn't you know kicked him out yeah
so that could change I would I would see
like his marriage isn't even on the rock
like his merit like they've both put
that to bed I would you know Tasha has
moved on with Terry and and she is kind
of discovering a new side of herself as
well so I mean let's say so I think you
know I it's it's the the ghost and
Angela relationship is a really like
kind of powerful love story between two
people that we don't I mean we see it on
TV but sometimes I don't know I feel
like they have a good they had us it
works in a special way in power we
haven't seen it well you know what when
you said in print I instantly thought of
Twilight and how they imprinted on one
another but we've never seen it in this
context of like you know crime and the
the power realm yeah I mean it's sort of
like they're like star-crossed lovers
it's like yeah you know Romeo and Juliet
they're on opposing side but they they
fell in love like it that's simpler time
before life dictated which direction
they're gonna go right so we'll see what
direction they go in after this clip
okay so Solomon wants to know from
YouTube the women of power don't really
get their hands too dirty
Kanan ghosts and Tommy are serial
killers who do you think will be the
first woman to cross that line
well it's interesting as Angela gets she
gets mics and of all killed Christine
who do you think like to do it
physically with their hands I mean get
their hands dirty yes so saloons gonna I
would say Tasha I could see that and you
said she has a journey ahead so we'll
see yeah what talks just capable of Anna
from YouTube says I love your sister
pads on power and orange is the new
black is she coming back this season is
pods coming back the season oh my
goodness I don't remember I mean she's
still in Angela's world she'll be back
next season
I know that but I don't actually I think
she's not coming back this season but
it's not it's cuz like Elizabeth
Rodriguez is an amazing actress and we
have to juggle her schedule and all
these other things so yeah she's
constantly she made but I'm not I'm not
sure I apologize I don't remember oh no
it's okay well hopefully we see her
Claudia Claudia from YouTube says will
we see you in any other show or movie
anytime soon I hope so
I mean I not as a way but fingers
crossed another character at some point
in time and you know not have to move
back in with my parents you keep saying
that but come on I mean being a series
regular as Angela this is a fickle
industry we can't you know fingers
crossed for her we're putting that out
there she's gonna get something great
speaking of oh yeah okay so Gary linen
he is going to be the coast showrunner
for season six Gary is amazing yeah what
yeah unique spin do you think he's gonna
bring to power well Kerry's actually
been there like from season two and so
it's not so much that he's gonna bring
like a unique spin other than he's just
you know getting to like be kind of like
like actually make sort of decisions in
tandem with Courtney and like going
through and it's it's um
he Gary is a native New Yorker he's you
know comes from the street and has an
incredible journey of really like coming
from very difficult conditions and
making an incredible life for himself
he's responsible for a lot of Tommy's
character and he he is a wonderful
writer and so I think he's just gonna
continue with great storytelling because
he has that backstory yeah really yeah
that's always great right now one thing
that everyone feels when they watch a
show like this and I know that we're
like rooted in crime but are you guys
close like off-screen like what's that
relationship like are you friends oh
yeah we're definitely a family because a
lot of it too as we all started this was
all of our first big show I'm you know
Mario had had you know work before but
this is his first time leading the helm
and the interesting thing though is when
we're shooting we only got to get to see
the characters that we work with and
then the offseason where we get to see
each other the most as like press but
won't get together and I'll have you
know dinner and all of that but also as
everybody's gotten fancier like
everyone's always like jet-setting off
here and there and so you know in the
beginning when nobody knew us then we
could have a lot more because I'm in
this place no I'm in doing this you know
you know and you're like no I know
Tasha's character yeah so notorious
daughter just celebrated her first
birthday did anyone go or did you send a
gift to her so cute yeah I was I think
mid-july and he was not in New York and
I think she had schedules yeah yeah I
got like I had yeah
no you're not no you're not I'm sure she
understands okay so um obviously we've
covered a lot of ground with the
characters but what do you think is
going to be the most
i thing that we see in Episode six like
what do not any spoilers but just like
the journey ahead okay so you're all of
the episodes are mush in my brain
this seems like it's going to be a heavy
ghost in Angela episode episode six yeah
it will be except I will tease that
Angela's working with Tasha so it's
gonna be how much does she let ghosts in
on their strategy or how much is ghosts
sort of compromise with his grief and
his sort of instability that they're
like are you kind of going to be that
balancing thing I mean when we do money
if I was like juggling their marriage
yeah all right all people yeah okay well
we have a lot of exciting things ahead
and I'm glad that we got a cut got to
cover some ground here I am really
excited for episode six so we're in for
a good one right yeah it always it's
gonna keep getting better by the end of
the season you know people are gonna be
like on the floor with fans we're
invested in which one Kendrick back
that's what we really want I mean who
doesn't I know
credible talent he's really great well
thank you guys so much I hope we
answered most of your questions if you
have any more go ahead and tweet her on
her social media and thank you guys so
much for tuning in be sure to subscribe
to our Facebook YouTube and we'll see
you guys for the next eighty live thanks
guys
[Music]
you